to go through that thank you for sharing  your account of what happened if you're  just joining us we are here at the  corner of blue bonnet and Burbank where  there is a reports of an active shooter  or situation that came in here at the  Wal Mart at Burbank and cubana the whole  area it is closed at Burbank a moment  ago we saw federal agents beginer  occurred here at the Walmart just around  12:00 noon in Baton Rouge if you're  familiar with this area we're at Burbank  and Bluebonnet there are a number of  subdivisions behind the Walmart Spring  Lake Fair Hill we see a looking for  possible suspect and we have Sheriff  Deputies here right now working the case  along with Baton Rouge police here on  the scene mom worked in the deli it was  actually being held on the opposite side  of the store of course everybody's  trying to make sure that they're safe  and get in touch with loved ones as this  is a very developing situation and it's  unclear now at this point if a shooter